I love dogs as much as the next guy.
I talk to dogs.
In preparing this book I spoke with dogs at
length.
Maybe I spoke more to dogs than with them.
But they’re all dogs, that’s the thing.
I know we all love our kennel club show we
all go there.
We obsess about whether our dog is a pug,
Jack Russell terrier mix with corgi overtones
and an oaky finish.
An approachable little dog, whatever.
They’re all dogs, okay.
And so the idea of a purebred is just a human
construct.
There’s no such thing – in a sense there’s
no such thing as a purebred dog.
And that’s – I don’t have a problem
with that.
That’s the way it is.
By the way you talk to any veterinarian and
they’ll tell you that a mutt is a much healthier
dog generally because they have this mix of
genes, they’re not inbred, they haven’t
made the same gene repeat too many times.
And so it’s funny, it’s charming to me
but there’s a great lesson to be learned.
Dogs are a descendent either from wolves or
from one ancestor before wolves.
But what you and I think of as a modern wolf
may or may not be the direct – what led
to a modern dog.
People talk about this as I’m writing the
book.
In the next five years it will probably be
resolved.
Somebody will come up with a definitive answer
to that.
But anyway, apparently these experiments were
done with foxes which are just the coolest
thing where the foxes that were friendlier,
that they were more comfortable around people,
they were allowed to approach, they were allowed
to use human food.
After just three generations they had floppy
scritchable ears and they were much more like
dogs.
And it just shows you that dogs are almost
certainly a result of a human wolf ancestor
interaction.
As we became friends with them they became
friends with us and we have a dependency that’s
charming.
It’s enriched both the dog lives and the
human lives.
It’s really quite an insight and it’s
a result of evolution.
The other lesson to be learned from dogs for
me is since they’re all dogs it’s just
– if you have a dachshund and a Great Dane
and they interact, can we say interact on
Big Think?
If they interact all you get is a dog.
You don’t get any new thing, new species,
you just get a dog.
In the same way if a Papua New Guinean hooks
up with a Swedish person all you get is a
human.
There’s no new thing you’re going to get.
You just get a human.
Japanese woman jumping the African guy, all
you get is a human.
They’re all humans.
So this is a lesson to be learned.
There really is, for humankind there’s really
no such thing as race.
There’s different tribes but not different
races.
We’re all one species.